what about the training you mentioned
the training of the auditor that's
really interesting so what's how lengthy
is that process it can take years
I mean one of that question I want to
ask is are people in Sea org like as an
auditor do you believe everything how
much
um is there a crisis of faith that
Creeps in religion you have a crisis of
faith when you start to wonder like does
God even exist so in this case how often
do you start to doubt
that some of the core beliefs of
Scientology are false
Scientology would say that Scientology
is not about beliefs it's about a
application of the techniques of
Scientology auditing to improve
someone's spiritual awareness and
ability
so the belief level of Scientology is
pretty much the stuff we've already
discussed the effectiveness of the
auditing process so the effectiveness of
the auditing process is one of the
things Hubbard says is that standard
Tech standard Scientology they call it
the tech the technology of how to
deliver auditing standard Tech Works 100
of the time when applied 100 correctly
well that's kind of unfalsifiable right
yeah because anytime it doesn't work it
wasn't applied correctly exactly
that's a nice little uh escape hatch to
pull on having a crisis of faith it
didn't work well
then obviously it wasn't applied
correctly that's where quality control
comes in their job is to nitpick and you
can always find one thing that wasn't
done correctly communism uh didn't work
because it wasn't implemented correctly
it's the it's always it's always it's
always an escape hatch with ideologies
that's right sure that's right I would
probably argue that Auditors
um are not in a position of having many
crisis of Faith because actually they're
usually seeing people for the most part
improve in some ways
through the process of auditing now
auditing can create like a state
somewhat of a euphoric State you feel
great you're just blown out of your head
you know you feel you're on top of the
world I've had that in some of my
auditing
as an auditor sorry no as the person
receiving auditing okay and so my point
is as an auditor doing a lot of auditing
you know you're going to have someone in
front of you called the the pre-clear is
the person in front of you who's getting
the auditing called the PC or the
pre-clear
they see over and over and over again
these pieces having these sort of
euphoric States and floating needles and
I feel great and fantastic oh thanks you
saved my life like
I've always said if Scientology if
people didn't find Scientology helpful
nobody would ever stay in Scientology
right
and so Auditors are pretty much the ones
doing the heavy lifting of what it even
means to be a Scientologist those guys
aren't the ones that you end up
um having crisis of faith I mean doing
Scientology auditing it doesn't require
that you believe just have faith that
you believe something you just have to
go through these motions and
scientologists one of the reasons
scientologists think this is all
scientific is because it's like I don't
care if you believe why this works I
care how you feel at the end of an
auditing session and empirically
speaking like anecdotal data is it
actually seems to improve people's lives
within the context so taking the outside
world out of it within this particular
organization
you're actually measurably seeing
Improvement yes is that is that some
degree real because like if you look at
a book like Animal Farm
where the pigs start to rule the other
animals and over time the life of the
animals gets worse and worse and worse
while the pigs keep saying that it's
actually getting better and better and
better again communism same thing the
the rationing is getting worse and worse
and worse less and less food but there's
constant reporting uh that there's more
and more food we're we're winning
hashtag I would argue that what you've
just described it could be
an identical description of what it
feels like and what it means to go up
scientology's bridge to total freedom
you are reinforcing to yourself that
everything's getting better and better
and better and and you'd be like
you don't spend time with your family
anymore yeah you're broke even though
you make a lot of money you're always
stressed you're you're at the beck and
call of these people who seem to run
your run your lives like how a
Scientologist feels about their own life
is
um it's very interesting to compare that
to how that person's life looks to their
non-scientology family members I get
contacted by a lot of people who've
never been in Scientology but like I got
a family member who's who's really deep
and I just can you help me understand
some things why is this person's life
like this why is this person's life like
this
so I I don't want to say that
scientologists do not actually I don't
want to say oh it's all in their heads
they think they're being helped but
they're really not that doesn't feel
honest you know but it's this thing
where if Scientology was just
getting auditing
when you wanted
about the subjects you wanted and you
could take it or leave it that would be
fine
it's it's the fact that it's part and
parcel to this entire organization and
this entire experience
that has as a part of that experience
taking everything from you demanding
everything from you controlling who you
can speak with controlling who you can
have relationships with who you have to
erase from your life this is where and
it's hard to it's hard to place one
pinpoint on this is where Scientology
goes wrong it's really hard to do that
because the good parts of Scientology
and the bad parts of Scientology
are all just Scientology yeah so there's
definition of what's bad for you and
it's probably in the beginning is bad
for you
um this almost just sounds like a
template of a toxic relationship you
know there's a bunch of stuff in this
world that's just not good for you so
the uh the authority the authoritarian
says like I'm just protecting you by
blocking you off from those negative
things and they're probably they are
probably negative things but then this
like
uh this Freedom starts closing in to
where you can't no longer speak freely
think freely act freely and there's some
I mean that's why sort of power corrupts
and absolute power corrupts absolutely
that person doing the controlling
actually starts getting that like
dopamine Rush of the controller that's
exciting and it's a vicious negative
cycle so you start out as it it starts
out good because you're trying to do
good for the person
um but then it somehow goes to [__]